i
hoy bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález a lo largo
de las últimas semanas hemos visto las
imágenes en la frontera de méxico en
donde miles de emigrantes la mayoría de
ellos son haitianos viven en un
campamento precario bajo un puente en la
frontera en estas dolorosas imágenes
debemos añadir las de la actuación
también de los agentes fronterizos del
lado estadounidense a caballo
persiguiendo a los migrantes y también
las deportaciones masivas los aviones
llegando a puerto príncipe- procedentes
de méxico y de eeuu con ciudadanos
haitianos que deben regresar a su país
de origen debido a la situación
irregular en la que se encuentran en
estos dos países la situación ya parece
que comienza a salirse de control méxico
registró la llegada de unos 147.000
indocumentados entre el mes de enero y
agosto indocumentados en términos
generales esto es el triple del año 2020
pero el caso más crítico como ya lo
estábamos diciendo es haití cerca de 2
millones de sus 11 puntos con millones
de habitantes han tenido que salir de
ese territorio de ese país de esa isla
en el caribe y muchos de ellos como
vemos en el mapa también están haciendo
una doble emigración porque en años
anteriores se fueron a países donde las
economías estaban teniendo un repunte
interesante como chile y brasil y ahora
ellos han tenido que viajar desde estos
países hacia países como ven ustedes hay
en el mapa hacia colombia hacia el
famoso tapón del darién para cruzar esta
selva llegar a panamá entrar al
territorio centroamericano y continuar
su travesía hasta el norte de méxico
para llegar a estados unidos ya lo
decíamos allí en estos países del sur no
pudieron conseguir trabajo estable
tampoco las condiciones legales para
poderse quedar por lo que eeuu es el
lugar donde esperan tener una nueva
oportunidad en sus vidas que es lo que
está sucediendo en haití cómo se está
manejando esta situación por parte de
los países de tránsito como veíamos en
el mapa que ya están desbordados como
colombia guatemala méxico perú bolivia
incluso panamá está la comunidad
internacional dando el apoyo y buscando
soluciones a esta problemática como
ayudar a haití un país inmerso en una
crisis política económica social y de
salud pública por la pandemia de covite
19 para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a erika guevara ella es
directora para las américas de amnistía
internacional ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de mexico y también está con
nosotros jeremy mcgillivray él es jefe
adjunto de la organización internacional
para las migraciones también se
encuentra en la capital mexicana
a los dos les les doy la bienvenida al
programa pero les recuerdo que también
los televidentes pueden ser parte de
este panel de opinión y pueden
participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
síganos como france24 bajo ese y arroba
sant y luego les recuerdo que nuestra
etiqueta es numeral del debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas para que ustedes sean
partícipe también de este debate también
les recuerdo que ahora el debate está
de lunes a jueves a las 7 y 20 hora de
bogotá como parte de la prolongación a
24 horas de la programación de france 24
pues tenemos un poco el contexto tenemos
a los invitados quiero comenzar con
erika en la ciudad de mexico en
preguntándole por qué ahora este
estallido de la migración sobre todo la
migración haitiana que ya lo veíamos
había comenzado con mayor fuerza después
del terremoto de 2010 pero qué es lo que
está pasando en este momento que vemos
que la situación se está agudizando
bueno yo creo que es importantísimo
poner el contexto que atraviesa en la
región una región que ya de por sí venía
enfrentando enormes desafíos en materia
de derechos humanos una crisis de
violencia generalizada en diferentes
países de nuestro continente
una crisis de desigualdad en donde
grupos de población históricamente
marginalizadas sufrían ya del embate de
políticas públicas que han
invisibilizado la situación que
enfrentaban y que todo esto ha venido a
exacerbarse con la crisis provocada por
kobe 19 y por la respuesta ineficaz que
han tenido muchos de los estados en el
continente para enfrentar los impactos
no sólo de carácter
en la salud sino de carácter económico
social que estamos viendo inclusive que
han exacerbado condiciones de violencia
estatal lo hemos visto durante la
represión de protestas de personas que
se toman las calles haciendo un reclamo
generalizado mostrar un hartazgo por las
condiciones de vida y la falta de
servicios públicos y eso eso es lo que
hoy día estamos viendo un reflejo de esa
realidad estamos viendo miles de
personas que están cruzando las
fronteras en búsqueda de protección
internacional precisamente por las
condiciones de precariedad y hoy día
vimos vemos una crisis exacerbada de
personas haitianas en necesidad de
protección que no vienen directamente de
haití en un gran número en una gran
mayoría que vienen de países
sudamericanos en donde también
lamentablemente han enfrentado
discriminación violaciones a sus
derechos económicos sociales y
culturales en muchos casos hemos visto
el desalojo forzado de familias
haitianas en países como brasil y chile
porque no tienen las condiciones para
mejorar sus ingresos en un contexto de
parte jeremy también allí en la ciudad
en la capital mexicana sus impresiones
de porque ahora esta crisis parece
agudizarse tal parece que estuvo en una
especie de pausa durante la pandemia de
kobe 19 pero ahora ha repuntado con gran
fuerza
gracias santiago pues concuerdo con con
erika en lo que planteaba yo que hay un
par de
consideraciones más que están llevando a
estas personas a moverse en la región en
realidad las personas haitianas como lo
hemos dicho se han estado moviendo desde
2010 a raíz del terremoto
pero últimamente además de la pandemia
vemos que por el cambio de
administración en eeuu y pues un mensaje
podríamos decir más positivo hacia los
migrantes en esto pues está llenando de
esperanza a personas que están buscando
mejores oportunidades
también está alimentando las redes de
tráfico de migrantes en los tratantes
los traficantes
usan este tipo de cambios en políticas
cambios en mensajes para alentar a la
gente a pagar sus servicios y emprender
camino
y en el caso específico de méxico hay un
asunto hay un asunto particular que ha
llevado a personas haitianas que ya
estaban en el sur del país a buscar y
moverse hacia la frontera norte y es que
las personas haitianas cuando ingresan
por el sur del país
la única opción prácticamente para tener
alguna documentación legal en mexico es
solicitar asilo en muchas de estas
personas lamentablemente no califican
para el asilo porque no vienen
directamente desde allí vienen de brasil
de chile de otros países en la región
donde estuvieron viviendo cierto tiempo
no significa que no necesiten protección
pero no
califican para el refugio y soy la comar
la entidad que está a cargo de
emitir
el refugio en méxico se ha visto
desbordada en los últimos meses y esta
desesperación ha llevado a muchas
personas haitianas a emprender camino
hacia el norte bueno ustedes dos han
puesto sobre la mesa varios puntos que
quiero analizar en este programa quiero
comenzar por un punto que destacaba
jeremy y es por qué está esta creencia
erika de que las políticas del gobierno
del presidente baiden son menos duras
creen que ha reducido los controles pero
en realidad el vicepresidente biden ha
mantenido las mismas políticas que
venían de la administración anterior
incluso hubo un llamado de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris en su
visita a méxico ya centroamérica
diciéndoles a los migrantes no vengan a
eeuu no es el momento para venir porque
la gente cree que las políticas
cambiaron y que son menos rígidas
bueno santiago
hay hay un elemento de narrativa muy
similar a lo que ocurre en méxico un
gobierno que desde una campaña electoral
promete un cambio paradigmático de las
medidas y políticas restrictivas
inhumanas y crueles de la administración
trump particularmente en relación al
sistema de asilo a los eeuu y lo mismo
ocurre en méxico creo que es importante
también mencionarlo él preside el actual
presidente de lópez obrador es su en su
campaña electoral también prometía en su
narrativa una política humanitaria de
trato
con pleno respeto a los derechos humanos
de personas necesidad de protección
migrantes personas solicitantes y
refugiadas y lo que vemos pues dista
mucho de la realidad a pesar de estas
narrativas a pesar de algunos esfuerzos
iniciales estos han sido insuficientes
no sólo para atender la crisis creada en
las fronteras por estas políticas
restrictivas sino también ha sido
insuficiente para atender las
necesidades apremiantes de una población
que está en necesidad de protección
los derechos de las personas tanto a
solicitar asilo oa buscar protección con
el famoso título 42 que fue una medida
impuesta por la administración trump
para el cierre de fronteras y que afectó
a miles de personas incluidas personas
que fueron digamos ex expulsadas
inmediatamente y si no se les permitió
la entrada a eeuu estamos hablando casi
de un millón de personas afectadas por
el título 42 y entre ellas un gran
porcentaje de personas en necesidad de
protección entonces ha habido un cambio
en narrativa ciertamente pero que en la
práctica no ha supuesto ningún cambio
significativo en el respeto a los
derechos humanos de las personas sino
todo lo contrario en la continuación de
estas medidas restringidas y que hoy día
estamos viendo que continúan perpetuando
esta situación de crisis con miles de
personas atrapadas en la frontera
jeremy el presidente mexicano
profundizando en lo que dice erika pues
méxico es este punto donde se está llega
donde se están acumulando los migrantes
y no pueden cruzar a estados unidos que
es el país de destino y méxico tiene en
cierta forma responsabilidad de qué
hacer con ellos se comprometió con eeuu
asumirá algunas labores sobre todo en la
frontera sur pero el presidente de
andrés manuel lópez obrador
protestó por la inacción de las
autoridades de eeuu y dijo textualmente
ya basta de discursos ya hace falta la
acción pero que hay de las acciones por
parte de méxico a quien se ha
comprometido méxico y qué papel tiene
que jugar méxico en toda esta en todo
este escenario que se está presentando
desde su perspectiva cualquiera que debe
ser
sí pues yo creo que méxico tiene
la responsabilidad de convertirse en un
país llamamos de destino de inmigrantes
esto es un poco el mensaje al inicio de
la administración de andrés manuel lópez
obrador
sin embargo las diferencias con la
anterior administración estadounidense
no no permitieron que eso kuajara y
ahora sí es cierto pues que tenemos una
postura más más dura contra la migración
en el sur de méxico
pero méxico tiene que convertirse en ese
ese destino para la población migrante y
vemos cada vez más que ahí hay gente que
busca quedarse en méxico así si tuvieran
la oportunidad la documentación
necesaria
hay muchas personas migrantes que están
empezando a ver a méxico como una buena
opción hemos estado aplicando
encuestas a personas migrantes que
cruzan el tapón del darién entre
colombia y panamá para
ver un poco cuál es la
intención de estas personas a dónde
quieren llegar además obviamente de sus
necesidades más apremiantes y es curioso
ver que cerca de un 40% de estas
personas en su mayoría haitianas
indicaban que su destino era méxico pues
querían dirigirse hacia méxico
en tijuana
hubo hace ya varios años una experiencia
bastante exitosa de integración de
personas haitianas hay un lo que llaman
el 0 xerez en tijuana
la gente está bien integrada en en la
ciudad entonces méxico tiene que
convertirse en ese destino pero para
poder hacerlo tiene que ofrecerle las
condiciones necesarias a las personas
migrantes para que lo puedan hacer erika
para cerrar un poco esta arista en
cuanto al papel de méxico en toda esta
situación también citó al presidente
mexicano él habla del compromiso que
había asumido washington de invertir
cuatro mil de dólares que serían 2000
para centroamérica y otros 2000
específicamente para méxico y no ha
llegado absolutamente nada vemos que
parte de la política y de ese plan que
presentó la vicepresidenta kamala harris
en su visita por centroamérica era
atacar el problema desde la raíz ofrecer
oportunidades a la gente en sus países
mejorar sus condiciones para no tener
que salir es total parece que entonces
no está en marcha y pues la situación
sigue tal cual como ha estado en los
últimos años la gente no tiene
oportunidades de empleo de educación
sobre todo seguridad y tiene que
abandonar el país esto entonces no está
en marcha
efectivamente santiago aquí ha faltado
pues no sólo cumplir con los compromisos
adquiridos pero apartado sobre todo una
acción concertada coordinada por parte
de los gobiernos de nuestra región los
gobiernos se han coordinado muy bien
para implementar políticas restrictivas
que violentan los derechos humanos de
las personas en situación de movilidad
que en su gran mayoría se trata de
personas en situación de movilidad
forzada yo creo que aquí es muy
importante hacer esta distinción
efectivamente en un
concepto estricto de la definición de
refugiado de la convención de 1951 pues
muchas personas no no serían merecedores
de este estatus de este reconocimiento
sin embargo en algunos países de nuestro
continente incluido méxico hay una
definición ampliada que se conoce como
la declaración de cartagena que
especifica que en la masividad de las
violaciones de derechos humanos la
violencia generalizada también son
componentes factores que obligan a las
personas a abandonar sus países y por
ende se les tiene que reconocer esa
necesidad de protección internacional y
respetarse ha sido lo que estamos viendo
es la negativa de estos gobiernos a por
un lado a reconocer que nuestra región
atraviesa por una gravísima crisis en
materia de derechos humanos la violencia
generalizada en centroamérica la
ineficacia de los estados para proteger
la corrupción la impunidad han sido
factores que no han sido discutidos en
estas relaciones bilaterales en estas
reuniones que se hacen al alto nivel y
que se sigue desplegando asistencia
técnica y financiera a gobiernos que
siguen marcados por la corrupción por la
impunidad por mecanismos autoritarios
para restringir los derechos humanos en
sus propios países entonces la medida
que no se atiendan las causas de raíz
pero de una manera integral las personas
van a seguir escapando las personas van
a seguir cruzando las fronteras con
guardia nacional con ejército sin él
y lo que está provocando es una crisis
de personas que ponen en riesgo su vida
o que cae en manos del crimen organizado
eddie kaye de mí ya estoy yo le añadiría
más allá de la corrupción y de los
factores que ha explicado erika le
añadiría que hay un plan para el
salvador para guatemala para honduras
para mexico incluso hubo reuniones en
costa rica para los nicaragüenses que
están saliendo hacia ese país que es
otra otra crisis pero no hay un plan
para haití qué es lo que pasa con el ti
porque no hay un plan específico para ti
que es tal vez el caso más crítico
jeremy
yo creo que
tomó por sorpresa a los gobiernos
involucrados
los los países por donde están pasando
las personas migrantes y es un poco
curioso porque
pues vista la pandemia vista las
condiciones socioeconómicas en la región
no no es sorpresa que se está intentando
estos movimientos
nosotros no nos estamos preparando para
este incremento en flujos migratorios en
en toda la región una vez que se
levantarán las restricciones a la
movilidad por la pandemia
yo creo que lo que lo que estamos
insistiendo nosotros con aquí en el
gobierno méxico y en la región en las
conversaciones que se están dando es en
dos puntos primero que tiene que ser una
respuesta regional
eso está claro es una respuesta
compartida no no le corresponde a eeuu
por sí solo a méxico por sí solo ni a
panamá es en cada país tiene que
contribuir en la respuesta y segundo es
ofrecer alternativas reales a estas
personas que están en movimiento en
documentación que les permita una
estadía regular en los países que los
permita trabajar que los permita acceder
a servicios
eso es básico para que las personas se
puedan integrar y en realidad una una
integración exitosa
evita que podamos ver en las escenas que
estamos viendo actualmente en el norte
de chile
pues que son lamentables pero que
pues son al final
[Música]
y un reflejo de la falta de
oportunidades que tienen las personas
haitianas para integrarse trabajar y
poder tener una vida una vida digna
además que el migrante haitiano tiene la
particularidad que no es hispanoparlante
que es bastante extraño dentro de la
región porque estamos acostumbrados a
ver a centroamericanos yendo a méxico
que finalmente hablan el mismo idioma
pero la idea no tiene la particularidad
es que no habla español y uno pensaría
que lo más lógico es bueno irse a eeuu
como lo hicieron en décadas anteriores o
irse a otros territorios francófonos en
el caribe como guadalupe o martinica
como también ya pasó en el pasado pero
pero ahora
la necesidad los obliga a enfrentarse a
escenarios distintos en brasil en chile
en argentina en colombia para poder
buscar una mejor calidad de vida
ya hemos analizado el punto de los
gobiernos hemos analizado la deficiencia
de los estados y esa falta de unión de
los países de américa latina para poder
encontrar una solución en común pero qué
hay de los organismos
desde el punto de vista suyo erika cree
que hay un desempeño adecuado de los
organismos están alertando sobre las
situaciones están actuando como debe ser
y sobre todo están evidenciando esa
situación de la red de tráfico y todo el
problema que esto conlleva que pues es
simplemente inhumano lo que sucede
bueno ya que quiere me habla de la falta
de recursos financieros la falta de
preparación que ha habido en general
para atender estas enormes crisis que
estamos viendo en el continente no
podemos olvidar que nuestro continente
lamentablemente enfrenta unas de las
mayores crisis en materia de movilidad
humana de desplazamiento forzado con las
personas refugiadas venezolanas con el
desplazamiento interno colombia y con
esta tragedia que estamos viendo hoy día
de personas centroamericanas y personas
haitianas que están cruzando por
diferentes fronteras en realidad ha
sobrepasado la realidad a la capacidad
que tienen los propios estados en lo que
tienen también los organismos
internacionales y sobre todo los
mecanismos intergubernamentales en el
propio continente como el sistema
interamericano y las múltiples agencias
de naciones unidas y ahí tiene que ver
otra vez con el compromiso de los
estados sin
compartir la carga financiera inclusive
que implica la atención de personas en
necesidad de protección internacional
organismos internacionales también están
atados de manos con la imposibilidad de
dar respuesta a todas las necesidades
apremiantes por un lado por otro lado
también está el factor de discriminación
tú preguntabas porque no hay un plan
para activo no no hay un plan para haití
claramente porque hay un tema de
discriminación racial histórico ha
habido un tema de explotación de
corrupción e inclusive con organismos
internacionales que han dado atención y
respuesta supuestamente humanitaria a
las múltiples crisis que atraviesa el
país inclusive la crisis del terremoto
del 2010 y que no se han rendido cuentas
no ha habido
injusticia y reparación para miles de
víctimas que también vieron sus derechos
violados por los propios organismos que
supuestamente tenían que protegerlos
entonces todo esto se aúna a una crisis
institucional por la que atraviesa el
continente con sus gobiernos incapaces
de responder y con la incapacidad que
tienen los organismos internacionales a
la falta de recursos financieros ya la
falta de voluntad de los propios estados
para darles jeremy entonces que se puede
hacer con el ticket hablamos del plan
para para sortear la situación
migratoria pero que hay del país como
tal que tiene instituciones muy débiles
acaba de pasar por una tragedia a nivel
político con el asesinato de su
presidente otro terremoto una economía
devastada la pandemia kobe 19 una
vacunación que no avanza
qué hacer con este país que puede
pedirle la o darle la comunidad
internacional a este país que es el más
pobre del hemisferio occidental
mira esa pregunta
yo si yo tuviera la respuesta no estaría
aquí
creo que estaría liderando el plan para
rescatar a haití si la tuviera éxito no
yo creo que lo que hay que tener claro y
tal vez es volviendo un poco a al
comentario que hacías de
este plan de la administración bailén
para atender las las condiciones de raíz
en el norte de centroamérica este plan
de 4 mil millones de dólares
y digo es un poco ligado a haití
hay que saber que atender estas causas
toma toma décadas hay que cambiar
estructuras en los países hay temas de
corrupción
entonces
no se cambia de un día para otro
en una administración estadounidense
no se va a cambiar de raíz las razones
por las cuales las personas están
saliendo ya sea del norte centro de
centroamérica o de haití entonces
obviamente hay que atender
esas esas causas estructurales pero
tener claro que va a ser un esfuerzo de
larga duración y al mismo tiempo saber
que las personas van a seguir migrando a
nosotros yo estuvimos presentes en
ciudad acuña en el norte de méxico la
semana pasada ofreciendo asistencia
humanitaria a las personas que estaban
cruzando el río
y quedaba claro que
sabían del riesgo de ser deportadas
hacia haití
pero el plan era claros así eran
deportadas y se iban a ir nuevamente del
país no saben que haití y sobre todo
para personas que llevan años fuera del
país
en este momento no les sobre no les
puede ofrecer
oportunidades para ellos y sus familias
y van a seguir migrando entonces hay que
atender en las causas estructurales a
largo plazo y al mismo tiempo saber que
la gente seguirá emigrando y hay que
buscar alternativas para estos procesos
eso es lamentable jeremy ver que la
mejor opción para una persona sea
enfrentarse a una deportación que sea
preferible una deportación perder la
vida cruzando una frontera y vivir en
condiciones de extrema pobreza en otro
país a enfrentar las condiciones a las
que está sometida en su país de origen
eso es lamentable yo creo que le
trasladó la misma pregunta a erika que
se puede hacer con haití y habló de una
intervención internacional
y asesoría de algún tipo de organización
es volver otra vez a enviar tropas
internacionales como ya lo hubo
un mandato internacional que se puede
solucionar para este país una opción que
puedan tener los haitianos
bueno yo coincido con jeremy es atender
todas las dos enormes desafíos por los
que atraviesa el país exacerbado por las
múltiples crisis que tú has mencionado
el magnicidio el terremoto reciente la
pandemia sólo el 0.2 por ciento de la
población ha sido vacunada de kobe que a
pesar que todo nuestro continente va
lento pues eso es inclusive en
comparación no no se compara con nada ni
siquiera con países que están en
situación de altísimo riesgo y pobreza
en continentes como áfrica no la
situación es verdaderamente crítica hay
una crisis institucional pero también
una profunda crisis en materia de
derechos humanos con una violencia que
afecta particularmente a personas
defensoras de los derechos humanos a
periodistas que en su intento por seguir
visibilizando lo que ocurre en el equipo
es también poner en riesgo la vida y en
ese contexto me parece importantísimo y
clave que se tome en consideración las
voces de la sociedad civil haitiana yo
creo que esa es una voz que ha estado
en los últimos años en todas las
respuestas que desde la comunidad
internacional se han dado la comunidad
no ha escuchado a las voces de las
organizaciones haitianas que existen de
las personas defensoras de los derechos
humanos que han propuesto cambios
significativos en la manera que se
atiendan los problemas en haití que se
respalde a las organizaciones
humanitarias y de derechos humanos que
operan en haití precisamente y que
combaten a la impunidad y la corrupción
existente precisamente para buscar sus
alternativas yo creo que es importante
que esas voces estén en las mesas de
toma de decisiones sobre qué tipo de
asistencia técnica y financiera requiere
el país para poder afrontar los
problemas existentes y lamentablemente
los problemas por venir porque el
retorno de todas estas personas generará
una crisis adicional las propias
autoridades migratorias de actividad ha
pedido una moratoria
humanitaria a los eeuu para que no
deporten a más personas porque han
declarado que no tienen la capacidad ni
siquiera para alimentar a los cientos de
personas que siguen siendo deportadas
estamos llegando al final del programa y
quiero preguntarles dentro de los
comentarios que recibí a través de las
redes sociales al hacer la difusión de
este tema para el programa de hoy muchas
personas preguntaban por las
deportaciones que es tal vez una acción
de mala imagen para los gobiernos pero
hay que aclarar que los gobiernos están
dentro del marco legal para hacer este
tipo de acciones como explicarle al
ciudadano común por qué eeuu puede
deportar enviar todos estos aviones
llenos de haitianos ya méxico está
haciendo lo mismo le hago la pregunta
jeremy puntual por favor para pasar a
las conclusiones
y este es un tema que como dices los
países tienen derecho a
tienen soberanía sobre sus fronteras y
tienen derecho a establecer las reglas
para que una persona pueda entrar al
país y permanecer
y pues las deportaciones aunque nosotros
buscamos
y que se puedan encontrar otras
alternativas las deportaciones al final
de cuentas si son una alternativa a
disposición de los países lo que donde
nosotros insistimos mucho es en cómo se
llevan a cabo estas deportaciones
en el caso de haití hemos insistido como
tú lo has mencionado es que no no hay
las condiciones
necesarias para recibir a personas
haitianas
en este momento
la crisis económica la crisis política
saliendo de un terremoto no hay las
condiciones para recibir a estas
personas y un tema muy delicado es que
en las casi 4.500 personas deportadas
desde eeuu en la última semana semana y
media hay muchas familias cerca más de
la mitad de las personas retornadas son
familias y este es otro tema donde
insistimos mucho esque
siempre tiene que
tomarse en cuenta el interés superior
del niño y de la niña en cualquier
decisión
sea con una persona inmigrante con
estatus irregular e irregular
llegó al final del programa quiero que
hagamos las conclusiones de lo que pueda
suceder en los próximos meses en torno a
esta situación y hago esta pregunta para
el cierre después de los hechos que
vimos en chile- en la ciudad de iquique
en el norte de ese país son hechos de
intolerancia de xenofobia en este caso
fue hacia venezolanos y haitianos pero
esto puede convertirse en una bola de
nieve no sólo en ese país sino en otros
países de la región comienzo por erika
para el cierre y puede ser este el
principio de una bola de nieve aún peor
de una ola migratoria más crítica
bueno sentido yo creo que es la
continuidad de una bola de nieve y yo
digo que es la continuidad lo que
vivimos estas imágenes dantescas
de
un grupo de personas que incendian no es
tener los pocos bienes que tiene un
grupo de población necesidad de
protección internacional lamentablemente
imágenes como éstas se van repitiendo en
muchos países de nuestro continente y
esta xenofobia está exacerbada
precisamente por las políticas de los
gobiernos por las políticas restrictivas
por las narrativas utilizadas por los
propios gobiernos para culpar a la
población es necesidad de protección de
los crímenes lo hemos visto en colombia
con la alcaldesa en bogotá que
lamentablemente muy detalladamente
utiliza el discurso oído para generar
este tipo de acciones enojo más lo hemos
visto con estas imágenes dantescas en
frontera de cómo se persigue a las
personas el trato que se les da y es una
narrativa que se construye a nivel
social entonces efectivamente debemos
tomar medidas concertadas coordinadas
de pleno respeto vamos a seguir viendo
esto jeremy 30 segundos para su
conclusión erika se me tomó casi el
tiempo completo adelante
concuerdo con erika porque el tema clave
es es acaba de empezar o está
continuando este tema no se va a ir la
gente se va a seguir moviendo es una
responsabilidad región regional y al
final es ofrecerle alternativas a las
personas migrantes pues hacer media eric
a los dos en ciudad de méxico les
agradezco por haber compartido con
nosotros sus puntos de vista en torno a
este tema ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales y les recuerdo el
debate hasta ahora de lunes a jueves en
la programación de france 24 a las 7 y
20 hora de bogotá siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]